despite the fact that the new flash solo
film has been in production for quite
some time
rumors have spread that lead actor Ezra
Miller has some disagreements with the
two directors as well as the production
of the script the main reason for this
is that for two directors John Francis
daley and Jonathan Goldstein want to
continue in the more humorous direction
which they have taken since Aquaman
while Miller wants the flesh to have a
serious and dark atmosphere since both
sides haven't come to an agreement yet
Miller has taken the initiative and
wrote together with comic book writer
Grant Morrison his own screenplay
version which will be presented next
week for Warner there is a lot on the
line after all as where I could leave
the studio in May due to his contract
coming to an end if they decide against
his version one I would then have to
either look for a new cast or cancel the
project completely so it remains
exciting how the studio will decide
because there seems to be much more to
it than just the script a few days ago
it became known that the long-awaited
Marvel blockbuster Avengers end came
would be released earlier than expected
so unusually for Avengers Disney has
announced the 24th instead of the 25th
of April 2019 in many countries such as
Germany Australia and France fans who
want to see the film in Midnight
previews can even watch it already
during the night from Tuesday to
Wednesday
Avengers endgame is even on its way to
become the most anticipated film of all
time
the recently released second trailer had
268 million views within 24 hours only
the first trailer of Avengers and game
with 289 million views in 24 hours can
be that score
the advance sale will also start shortly
and you can count the days almost on one
hand until Avengers end game will be
shown in many cinemas on April 24 while
other countries like the USA have to
wait until April 26th to see the
long-awaited Marvel film after we
reported last week that Netflix wants to
focus more on interactive content like
Black Mara Bandersnatch in the future
the first content has been announced
already Netflix is set to have one
Survival I can bear grylls for a new
interactive documentary series
a former soldier of the pretty special
unit SAS who became known mainly through
man versus wild has signed a profitable
contract with Netflix to give you an
idea Netflix has published a small
teaser on YouTube the series will be
called u vs. wild and will be available
on Netflix from April 10th starting with
8 episodes
although director James Gunn has not
been working for Marvel for quite some
time he will now participate in the
third guardians of the galaxy part
according to Marvel boss Kevin Feige the
pressure on Disney was big anyway after
all many fans and Drax actor Dave
Bautista urged Cannes returned with the
popular director now meeting Disney
board member alan horne it was clear to
both sides that James Gunn would return
as director of the third guardians film
after the head of harmonious talk John
himself who has played a large part in
the popularity of the Guardians series
seems to be very grateful in a short
statement he says I am tremendously
grateful to every person out there who
has supported me over the past few
months I deeply appreciate this nice
decision and I'm excited to continue
making films that investigate the ties
of love that binds us all from the
bottom of my heart thank you despite the
euphoria about his return Gann is still
working on the second part of Suicide
Squad so he will not be able to return
to the Marvel Universe until it's
completed a small disappointment for all
Guardian fans after all the release date
of the Suicide Squad is in summer 2021
the murder of Disney MTV giant Fox is
complete thus Disney now not only
completely owns all the rights on 20th
Century Fox but can also include some
superheroes in the Marvel Universe in
the future Disney has also taken over
the assets of x-men and Deadpool Disney
boss Bob Iger comments our acquisition
of 21st Century Fox was driven by our
strong belief that the addition of these
great businesses brands franchises and
talent will allow us to move faster rich
father and aim higher especially when it
comes to building direct connections
with consumers
he also said that Disney has never been
short on ambition and he is rapidly
transforming Disney in order to thrive
in this new and exciting time another Q
Disney has achieved is an attractive
participation in the Hilo streaming
service thus the next step has been
taken to make its upcoming streaming
service Disney Plus even more exclusive
and the competition less attractive
netflix track again from May 24th on
Netflix will again provide an exclusive
horror thriller to their customers and
it's said to be a terrifying experience
only very few of you will have heard of
the film the perfection which celebrated
its premiere last summer at the
Fantastic Fest in Austin Texas the
following hymns of praise from the
critics speak for themselves though as
you can look forward to a crash drama
roller coaster ride that more than one
skilfully tricks the viewer many
journalists are also of the opinion that
one should refrain from any summary in
order to unfold the film's full effect
we will leave it at that - and look
forward to may 24th when the perfection
with get-out actress Allison Williams
starts exclusively on Netflix
[Music]